[Musique]
le défaut de concert sur entre alliés
que nous avons constatées dans la
décision prise par l'australie et les
états unis c'est la permanence de
réflexes d'une époque que nous espérions
révolue l'alliance est pas d'allégeance
nous sommes dans une alliance pas pour
être sous traitants et vassaliser nous
renouvelons notre engagement avec
l'union européenne comme un partenaire
fondamental face aux enjeux importants
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
qui nous ne cherchons pas une nouvelle
guerre froide mais voilà ça n'ira pas
plus loin pas un mot pour la france
titrait lci tout de suite après une
dernière image pour terminer juste avant
la prise de parole de bail donne le
micro et le public ont été soigneusement
désinfecter faut dire que ces vols sont
à rocky parlait juste avant et le
président brésilien n'est pas vaccinée
d'après ce qu'on me dit en fait emmanuel
macron le savait depuis juin je vous
savez un secret à 3 en concédant la vie
je pense qu'il n'a aucune chance d'être
élu mais parce que il suscite
certes
incontestablement il a les électeurs
potentiels mais il suscite aussi
énormément
de rejet
la france est méprisé par les états unis
par la grande bretagne mais ce qui est
encore peut-être plus choquant c'est
l'absence de réaction forte de l'europe
elle a mis du temps mais lors des
discussions les ministres ont exprimé
clairement leur solidarité à l'égard de
la france
cette annonce va à l'encontre des appels
à une plus grande coopération avec
l'union européenne dans la région indo
pacifique à quoi nous sert l'amp a rien
à rien est ce que les allemands nous ont
soutenus non on a fait une à l'europe
avec des allemands qui sont en vérité
soumis aux américains et qu'ils
choisissent toujours les américains
contre nous cette rupture de confiance
appel des réflexions l'aude entre
européens sur la conception que nous
faisons des alliances et des
partenariats
peut-on accepter que tous les grands
cabinets de conseil mckinsey les grandes
banques les fonds d'investissement
goldman sachs
et installe niang qui sont soumis au
patriot a ouï dire que la totalité
informations qui circulent dans ces
cabinets sont directement capturés et
sont sous législation américaine tout le
monde a voulu croire en france que
c'était trump qui posait problème et
qu'après on allait redevenir les
meilleurs amis du monde on n'a jamais
été les meilleurs amis des etats-unis
jamais il y a de la part de des états
unis une volonté de monter en puissance
dans l' escalade la confrontation avec
la chine cette confrontation
elle pourrait avoir je ne suis pas en
train de le prédire naturellement elles
pourraient avoir une dimension militaire
est ce cela que nous voulons cette image
qui a fait le tour du monde et qui
choque la mairie ces gardes frontières à
cheval qui tentent de repousser les
migrants fouet à la main ça suscite la
polémique car ça fait écho aux heures
sombres évidemment de l'amérique ils
crament la caisse de nivelles à être en
relation assez parlant en tout cas il
fait payer ces mesures électoral par la
dette et donc par les impôts de demain
donc oui il y aura d'autres révoltes un
point commun avec la période d'avant la
révolution française c'est qu'on
accumule des dettes on accumule des
dettes parce qu'on n'arrive pas à faire
payer les privilégiés au moment de la
révolution française et ceux aujourd'hui
qui manie le séparatisme fiscale elle
trône devant l'hôtel de ville de rouen
depuis plus d'un siècle et demi mais
cette statue de napoléon pourrait
bientôt être remplacée par une statue
féminine cerné par le magma cette maison
en feu s'effondre en quelques secondes
comme elle une centaine d'habitations a
été détruite sur l'île engloutis par des
rivières de feu et de rolls
incandescente